this is a full story and this is the  last time all telling it's been a year  since xxx today Seon passed away the  rapper was shot leaving a motorcycle  dealership in Florida On June 18 2018  Billy Eilish who has friends of them  paid tribute on her Instagram story in a  series of three slides she wrote quote  miss you hope you're okay up there  and long live you Billy's new album  largely deals with themes of life and  death the album is called when we all  fall asleep where do we go bury a friend  try to wake up Billy bonded with pal bad  baby at exes funeral so how do you guys  know each other  um so we had ZM a couple times and then  sadly the first day we met was I shoulda  did it X had passed she came to my house  always listening music and cried all day  like some little [ __ ] but yeah oh  yeah and ever since then we've been real  tight  you